before I get to the questions from the
internet I just want to say I understand
part of the reason why the NFL is so
successful that was really what I was
somebody
economically they don't have the strikes
that baseball does and all that stuff I
get it the sports great you know it's
fast action they kill each other and you
know we looked but did you want to rebut
that at all did you think I had no point
there no I'm a nascar guy so I because
there's nothing more people think
driving is erratic sand shooting animals
is a sport to me okay let's go to some
of the other how do you think American
exceptionalism is viewed by other
countries well you're from another
country yeah yeah I mean it does sound
like we're saying that we are better
just because we're born American I mean
I mean that's missing the point you
started to talk about this during the
show it's not genetic we're not born
better it's the way our ethics are in
the way we but we have a system so I'm
predicting that we have a system that
over 200 years has pulled more people
out of poverty than any society on the
history of Earth and we did it through
the concept of freedom that's 35 years
for everybody else what I mean besides
people look like you talk about like me
and my honestly the idea just started to
like really kind of be more inclusive
and I think that that many recent years
the poverty thing is going the other way
but but you know more people are in
poverty than they were 10 years and kept
a lot more dead and executed and
repressed than any other michael you
probably know this America I believe has
more diversity in its elected officials
than any other country we do and I think
I think this is actually something I
read while back not true that Russia
does not have a single black man :
the mark we are Iping to know this
monistic we are 90th in the world in
percentage of women in government and
the first time black men ever got to
speak from the well of the Congress were
like during Bill Clinton when they were
impeaching you the first time I black my
never got to speak from the will of
Congress was is the first time and the
first time a black man ever in 1870
there were black pieces the imagine
since the Emancipation Adam Clayton
Powell certainly spoke from the well the
house back in 1960 yes what what what I
want to say is that this country I love
this country and every time you have an
objection to it people say that you
don't but there have been a lot of
things for sure that the first time a
black man ever did a color commentary
was when Gumbel did it in the Superbowl
like 10 12 years ago there there are so
many reasons that that you should be
proud of what happened was happening now
with Obama and the idea that so many
people that look a lot of the
exceptionalism the concept of that
really is born in in the journey that is
America in other words you come here
however you get here and some of us got
here a little easier than others we know
that that's what some of us some of us
had to take the long way around but the
reality of it is the reality reality of
America is what you do with what you got
and what you get here and how you strong
me even even in the dark days for a lot
of african-americans there were wealth
there was wealth being created there was
entrepreneurism that was being developed
and there was a seedbed that was placed
that allows you and me to sit here today
because of the Handy the handle hammers
and others out there who've been out
there who were out on the forefront
taking advantage of a corrupt a racist
and a system that has disadvantaged them
that is the strength of this country's
that you even in that situation you're
still able to excel what are people
outside of America is a great country
it's a wonderful country but
exceptionalism is a very worrisome
doctrine because it suggests you don't
have anything to learn from anybody else
and you don't owe anything to anybody
[Applause]
founding fathers were Englishmen who
were insisting on the rights of
Englishmen they were building on the
heritage of Magna Carta in 1215 right
you know in my country and Canada you
know that this would've be the big you
know a Canadian things it's it's
absolutely unacceptable for somebody to
be bankrupted that's the single largest
[Applause]
not to either appreciate what other
countries have to say they have nothing
to learn and that they don't have like
Mitt Romney's book Mitt Romney very well
be your nominee he has a book his book
out you know they all have a book when
they run it's kind of their white paper
it's called no apologies the case for
American greatness really no apologies
no that does those aren't connected look
your first question was what does what
does no apologies and greatness you can
have be great and have some apologies
your clothes nobody what if people
outside of our country think of us and
the prime minister said dimly let me
just ask you this if we took down all
immigration laws all borders across the
world do you think we'd have a net gain
in population or decrease I think that
said I think me to make money I think
that the people who this country I think
I think really and truly maybe we're
thinking too much about it maybe it's
just team pride because I'm a Georgian
and I'm happy to be from Georgia and I'm
sure you know you guys are happy to be
from your home states and there's
nothing wrong with it
and I went to school Michigan State I
used to sneak over the Canadian border
every chance I got because I love your
country
Oh actually we're just scared you know
live off their brothers reputation who
would live off what their brother did we
do that now they were exceptional men
who did a lot of great things in this
country but we've devolved into very
petty very small minded people and I if
you look at what we we are degrading not
involved we're becoming smaller I don't
feel that way you know I've been in that
pressure cooker in Washington DC I got
to tell you there are a lot of great
Democrats there a lot of great
Republican there are a lot of great
great democrat rosa DeLauro who's one of
the most liberal members up there is one
of my closest friends without any
question about it I mean we get along
great she was chairman of the AG
committee they're lost now I'm gonna be
and we're gonna work together Sam Farr
is in the mix I mean we've got a lot of
good friendships but it doesn't say all
newspapers but just weather it and I'll
give if we're so exceptional why do our
corporations ships our job to other
countries why do people knowing me
because we have the second because we're
we don't do the job right
we very expensive yeah lower the
corporate tax rates right here it's more
of an education let me test if you can't
call city if city if I call a city group
to dispute my credit card I don't even
understand what the key I'll pay my beer
when I understand what the [ __ ] you
I want to pay you I just don't know what
you see so if you can't even do that
it's because corporations don't even
believe the idea of what you say we
really do I want to say this not only do
I like some Democrats but some
Republicans like well hear something
from says hey bill love you Michelle
Bachman I was with Michelle this morning
and I was really hey I am gonna go see
who did who does she think she was
writing this to our differences we can
get together and okay well I will I also
have you Ronald Reagan booked a oh I
will
that's pushing it too far and I'm stand
but I will take them both and put them
in my hope chest
thank you very much for this wonderful
panel and thank you